[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Marie taslomka guten Abend es
ist haushaltswoche im Deutschen
Bundestag und dazu gehört natürlich dass
der Entwurf des Bundesfinanzministers
von der Opposition in der Luft zerrissen
wird die einen werfen ihm sozialen
Kahlschlag vor die anderen
finanztricksereien soweit so normal ganz
normal ist diese haushaltswoche aber
nicht wenn man bedenkt wie schwer sich
die Koalition damit Tat überhaupt einen
Haushalt aufzustellen über Monate hatte
man sich gegenseitig blockiert Christian
Lindner legte im Frühjahr noch nicht mal
wie sonst üblich erste Eckwerte zu
Orientierung vor mit Hängen und Würgen
ist dieser Etat am Ende entstanden
anders kann man es nicht sagen dazu
gleich noch ein Gespräch mit Christian
Lindner nach dem Bericht aus dem
Bundestag von Frank Buchwald
Auftakt der Haushaltsdebatte da schlägt
die Stunde des Finanzministers Lindners
Botschaft heute Deutschland muss raus
aus der Schuldenspirale vererbt der arme
Onkel Schulden kann man das Erbe
ausschlagen beim Bundeshaushalt
funktioniert das nicht und deshalb haben
wir auch eine moralische Verantwortung
gegenüber denjenigen die nach uns kommen
tatsächlich gibt der Bund sehr viel
weniger aus als in den
corona-krisenjahren der Etat für 2024
hat ein Volumen von
445,7 Milliarden Euro die
Neuverschuldung liegt nominell bei 16,6
Milliarden deutlich weniger als in
diesem Jahr damit hält Lindner die
Schuldenbremse ein das Bild aber trüge
kritisiert die Opposition
nicht finanzieren ohne die buchungsrecht
wäre der gesamte Spruch sofort vorbei
wegen dieser nebenhaushalte nämlich
liegen die Neuverschuldung deutlich
höher aber ein solche Sondervermögen
kann auch der Verteidigungsminister
zurückgreifen 100 Milliarden für die
Bundeswehr falsch findet die Linke
Programm für die deutsche und vor allen
Dingen für us-rüstungskonzerne diese
Bundesregierung hat ein Herz für Panzer
aber nicht für Kinder und das ist das
falsche Signal
Sondervermögen auch der
Bundesrechnungshof sieht dieses
Instrument seit Jahren kritisch die
politische Diskussion um den Haushalt
kommentiert die Behörde ausdrücklich
nicht generell aber beschränkten solche
nebenhaushalte das Budgetrecht des
Parlaments durch diese Art
töpfchenwirtschaft hat der Bundestag als
Haushaltsgesetzgeber gerade keinen
klaren Blick mehr auf die tatsächliche
Lage der Bundesfinanzen nun geht der
Haushalt mit allen nebenhaushalten in
die parlamentarische Beratung Härtetest
für Lindner sparcours er will vor allem
den Anstieg der Sozialausgaben begrenzen
einzig und allein ihre kleine Fraktion
hier in der Mitte hat ihn Applaus
gespendet was sie vorgestellt haben Herr
Minister ist ganz offensichtlich nicht
der Haushaltsentwurf der Regierung
sondern der Haushaltsentwurf der FDP
man hat fast den Eindruck Christian
allein zu Hause
auch vom grünen Koalitionspartner
nämlich kommen kritische Töne fast eine
Kampfansage das Parlament ist der
Haushaltsgesetzgeber wir entscheiden am
Ende nachher wieder Bundeshaushalt 2084
aussieht und ich kann Ihnen sagen wir
wollen ein Haushalt der Zusammenhalt
stärkt und wir werden zentral an
Veränderungen Verbesserungen arbeiten
und ich freue mich auf die Beratung wie
wir diesen Bundeshaushalt noch besser
und gerechter machen können
so steht im Finanzminister wohl ein
heißer Herbst bevor die Rückendeckung
des Kanzlers wird Lindner brauchen im
Kampf um sparen und die Schulden im
Schatten
dann fragen wir doch den
Bundesfinanzminister guten Abend Herr
Lindner guten Abend Frau Slomka wenn
schon so schwer war diesen Entwurf
zusammen zu kriegen wie heißt wird denn
dann dieser Herbst bis zur
Verabschiedung
es ist jetzt Sache des Parlaments den
Haushalt 2024 zu beschließen aber die
Leitplanken sind klar die eine
Leitplanke heißt die Schuldenbremse gilt
und die andere Leitplanke ist dass wir
ja auf Steuererhöhungen verzichten
wollen also keine Belastung für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger und die Betriebe
denn das werden der jetzigen
Wirtschaftslage falsch
das im Parlament jetzt aus den eigenen
Reihen soweit man die Koalition als
eigen rein bezeichnen kann nicht so
wahnsinnig viel Applaus kam
es war in der Tat eine sehr schwierige
Haushaltsaufstellung da gibt es gar
nichts zu beschönigen es musste auf
manches wünschbare verzichtet werden
weil wir eben die haushaltspolitischen
Realitäten anzuerkennen haben wir können
nicht auf dauerpolitik auf Pump machen
und wir dürfen auch die Inflation nicht
mit immer neuen Staatsausgaben die
Schulden finanziert sind Beuern das ist
natürlich ein schwieriger Prozess aber
wir haben ihn bewältigt die fahren an
einen Staat durchaus auch auf Pump leben
kann das ist ja umstritten auch unter
Ökonomen es ist auch umstritten ob die
Schuldenbremse so wie sie jetzt ist
eigentlich wirklich sinnvoll ist selbst
die Bundesbank oder der internationale
währungsform die jetzt nicht im Verdacht
stehen irgendwie sozialistisch
angehaucht zu sein sagen da könnte man
eigentlich etwas locker darauf machen
ist gäbe den Staat mehrere Dramen
diese internationalen Empfehlungen muss
man sehr differenziert betrachten wir
nehmen Sie in Deutschland manchmal auch
sehr selektiv wahr in der Sache aber
geht es um folgendes wir müssen auf der
einen Seite Prioritäten setzen
Investitionen in die Infrastruktur in
die Digitalisierung in die
Modernisierung unserer Volkswirtschaft
und das tun wir wir haben auf
Rekordniveau Investitionen eingeplant in
den nächsten Jahren und das gelingt weil
wir Prioritäten setzen die entscheiden
also was ist wirklich erforderlich und
was ist entbehrlich was ist vielleicht
auch veraltet und deshalb verbinden wir
in den nächsten Jahren beides auf der
einen Seite die Schuldenbremse die wir
brauchen damit wir auch im nächsten
Krisen Reserven haben mit
Zukunftsgestaltung aber es sind ja doch
es werden ja weniger öffentliche
Investitionen im nächsten Jahr getätigt
als im vergangenen also das wird ja
schon zurückgefahren die Möglichkeiten
des Staates zu investieren wegen der
Schuldenbremse Frau Slomka ich
vergleiche nicht die Jahre der Pandemie
und des Energie landkreisschocks sondern
ich vergleiche das vor krisenniveau 2019
vor der Pandemie mit
2024 und da ist die Situation so dass
wir von etwa 37 Milliarden auf 54
Milliarden Euro die Investitionen
steigern und zwar nicht nur ein
absoluten Zahlen von 10% Investitionen
auf 12%, das zeigt die Schuldenbremse
ist keine Investitionsbremse sie ist nur
eine Erinnerung daran dass wir nur das
ausgeben können was wir erwirtschaftet
haben und deshalb entscheiden müssen
aber wenn das eigentlich so super klappt
mit der Schuldenbremse warum brauchen
sie denn dann so viele Schattenhaushalte
um die Ausgaben tätigen zu können die
sie aufgrund der Schuldenbremse
eigentlich nicht tätigen können nein das
ist nicht ganz richtig ich nutze wie
alle meine Vorgänger in den vergangenen
Jahrzehnten neben Haushalte
Sondervermögen für Aufgaben die über
mehrere Jahre verteilt sind also nehmen
Sie zum Beispiel die Hilfe für die Flut
Opfer da hat mein Vorgänger ein
Sondervermögen eingerichtet damit es
dort verlässlich die zugesagte
Unterstützung gibt und die Strom- und
gaspreisbremse finanziere ich auch über
ein sogenanntes Sondervermögen obwohl es
Schulden sind ist ein Euphemismus aber
so heißt es eben in Technik ja die
rechtstechnik ist Sondervermögen ich
sage dann lieber Sonderprogramm weil wir
nicht wussten wie die Preisentwicklung
bei Strom und Gas ist wie viel Geld
benötigen wir zu welchem Zeitpunkt
deshalb außerhalb des Haushaltes was
aber entscheidend ist ist wie ist die
Schuldensituation des Staates insgesamt
Kernhaushalt und nebenhaushalt und hier
gibt es eine ganz klare Zahl die
Schuldenquote des gesamtstaats und die
wird in den nächsten Jahren sinken
anders als der Eindruck erweckt wird sie
singt und schon in wenigen Jahren werden
wir auf das vor krisen-niveau auf das
Niveau vor der corona-pandemie
zurückgekommen sind aber die Frage ist
ob das überhaupt so wünschenswert ist
angesichts der Aufgaben die es gibt ich
meine wir haben diese ganzen schwarze
Null Jahre wo alles immer sich nur darum
Geräte die Schulden möglichst gering zu
halten ja erlebt und jetzt sehen wir
welchen Zustand unsere Straßen sind in
welchem Zustand unsere digitale Struktur
ist in welchem Zustand die Deutsche Bahn
und ihr Schienennetz ist also es gibt ja
nun nicht wenige Ökonomen die sagen das
ist jetzt eigentlich nicht die Zeit um
wieder zu sparen es ist auch noch nicht
die neue Normalität von der sie auch
heute im Bundestag Sprachen alles was
Sie über die Defizite und
investitionsbereiche gesagt haben stimmt
und ich könnte noch weitere hinzufügen
das Grone Investitionen die wir übrigens
brauchen sind private Investitionen um
unsere Wirtschaftskraft zu erhalten
müssen die Betriebe investieren und
nicht alleine nur der Staat also das was
sie sagen stimmt aber das ist kein
Widerspruch wir setzen eben nur klare
Prioritäten wie investieren mehr als
vorher unser Problem heute ist nicht das
fehlende Kapital im Haushalt das ist da
ich habe die Sorge dass das was wir
eingeplant haben an Geld gar nicht
genutzt werden kann weil unsere
Planungs- und Genehmigungsverfahren
immer noch zu langsam sind die müssen
schneller werden wenn dann noch Geld
fehlt
da ist die klare Zusage das werden wir
dann notfalls finden
das Finanzminister danke für das
Gespräch bitte schön
das Interview haben wir vor zwei Stunden
geführt nach russischen Angaben hat es
auch letzte Nacht wieder Drohnenangriffe
auf Moskau gegeben solange es nur nur in
Anführungsstrichen Drohnen sind die
abgefangen werden halten sich die
Schäden in Grenzen es sind bislang eher
psychologische Nadelstiche seitens der
Ukraine dieser Krieg der Irland zerstört
soll auch in der russischen Hauptstadt
zumindest zu spüren sein der weil die
ukrainische Armee weiter bodengewinne
verzeichnet im Süden in der Region
saporicia aber der Preis dafür ist
entsetzlich hoch das gilt genauso für
die östlichen frontgebiete dort ist
unsere Reporter Hannah Hebestreit
unterwegs er zeigt wie die Armee
versucht die Moral ihrer Truppen
hochzuhalten und sei es mit Musik
ukrainisches Militär unterwegs zu einem
Ort irgendwo im Wald gleich hinter der
Front
mitten im Krieg machen Sie hier eine
Pause ein paar Stunden trägt die Musik
ihre Gedanken zu einem Leben weit weg
von Explosionen tot oder Kugelhagel es
geht um große Gefühle
Miroslav ist in der Ukraine ein
bekannter reggae-interpret und war
bekennender Pazifist jetzt singt er in
der Armee
[Musik]
das ist ein Krieg in dem es um unsere
Existenz geht wir müssen uns verteidigen
deshalb bin ich hier
ich kämpfe für meine Familie meine
Kinder für mein Land und solange das so
ist kann ich meine Pazifismus
wer hier sitzt hat in den letzten
Monaten Kameraden verloren hat gekämpft
vielleicht getötet das hinterlässt
Spuren in der Seele auch in der Körper
intakt ist
gestern haben viele noch feindliche
Schützengräben oder Bunker gestürmt
jetzt sind Sie hier um abzuschalten man
spürt dass sie gerade noch schlimmes
durchgemacht haben
davon sollen sie sich hier erholen
körperlich und vor allem emotional
die Soldaten sind müde nicht kriegsmüde
sondern müde vom Warten das auch ihnen
die Stunde schlägt
[Musik]
den ganzen Sommer schon ist die
kulturtruppe im Hinterland der Front
unterwegs
manchmal spielen Sie mehrere Auftritte
an einem Tag für Kriege und Künstler ist
das Neuland
und dann erleben Sie doch viele
Emotionen das ist das Wichtigste danach
sind sie viel lockerer wir machen Fotos
reden die Stimmung ändert sich das ist
das Wichtigste für mich
sie leisten psychologische Ersthilfe am
Rande des Schlachtfelds solange der
Krieg tobt ist Kultur immerhin ein
kleiner Trost
[Musik]
Deutschland hat heute übrigens neue
Munition für die Geparden die
flugabwehrpanzer geliefert sie helfen
der Ukraine ja ihre Städte und Truppen
zu schützen aber die Munition ging zu
neige die Schweiz hätte noch welche
gehabt verweigert aber den Verkauf also
hat die deutsche Rüstungsfirma
Rheinmetall neue produziert zu diesen
und anderen Themen finden Sie wie immer
Informationen auch online auf ZDF heute
und jetzt geht es erstmal bei dir weiter
Gundula zunächst auch noch mal mit den
Grollen von Krieg weltweit sind im
vergangenen Jahr so viele Menschen durch
Streumunition ums Leben gekommen wie
seit 2010 nicht mehr insgesamt mehr als
1170 die meisten Opfer von Streumunition
habe es in der Ukraine gegeben heißt es
in den Bericht der Beobachtungsstelle
für Streumunition dort sein 916 Menschen
dadurch verletzt oder getötet worden im
Folgenden Einsatz von Streumunition gab
es bei einem Angriff auf grammatance 53
Menschen wurden damals getötet und über
100 verletzt
das Welternährungsprogramm der Vereinten
Nationen warnt vor einer dramatischen
Verschärfung der humanitären Lage in
Afghanistan Fördermittel sein gekürzt
worden deswegen könnten mittlerweile 10
Millionen Menschen in dem Land nicht
mehr versorgt werden so die Organisation
sie brauche für die nächsten sechs
Monate rund eine Milliarde Dollar für
Afghanistan die Zeit laufe davon
mehr als eine halbe Million Menschen
haben in der ersten Jahreshälfte Asyl in
EU-Staaten beantragt das ist laut
asylagentur der EU ein Anstieg um 28
Prozent im Vorjahresvergleich und der
höchste halbjahresstand seit 2015 die
meisten Anträge kamen weiterhin von
Menschen aus Syrien sowie aus
Afghanistan und der Türkei mit fast
einem Drittel gingen die meisten Anträge
wieder in Deutschland ein
zugleich steigt die Zahl der illegalen
Einreise nach Deutschland die
Bundespolizei registrierte im August
rund 15.000 100 unerlaubte
Grenzübertritte ein Höchstwert in diesem
Jahr in dem bislang insgesamt mehr als
71.000 Menschen
illegal einreißen heftige Kritik an
Innenministerin Fräser kommt von der
Gewerkschaft der Bundespolizei deren
Vorsitzender sagte der Zeitung Welt man
habe seit Monaten warnt der Bund ließe
Länder und Kommunen im Stich
Griechenland ist erneut von Extremwetter
betroffen nach zuletzt verheerenden
Waldbränden wüten nun in mehreren Teilen
des Landes heftige Unwetter mit
Starkregen besonders betroffen ist die
Mitte Griechenlands dort sind viele
Ortsstraßen überflutet Strom und
Handynetze vielen zeitweise aus ein
Mensch kam bislang ums Leben der
griechische Wetterdienst warnt weiter
vor ungewöhnlich hohen Regenmengen in
den nächsten Tagen mit bis zu 700 Litern
pro Quadratmeter
die rasante wirtschaftliche Entwicklung
China es war ja lange Jahre ein Quell
der Freude für die deutsche
Autoindustrie vor allem
vw-geschäft heute ganz anders da fragt
sich nur ob die deutschen Autobauer und
auch die deutsche Politik dabei nicht
übersehen haben dass China frühzeitig
anfingen auf die Produktions von
Elektroautos zu setzen eigene
chinesische Modelle mit denen sie den
deutschen nun in Deutschland Konkurrenz
machen man sieht immer mehr von Ihnen
bei uns im Straßenbild kein wundern sie
sind ja auch viel billiger das
Bundeskanzler Scholz auf der
Internationalen Automobilausstellung
heute die Innovationskraft der deutschen
Autobauer lobte hatte insofern ein
bisschen was vom Pfeifen im Walde Peter
Aumeier und Alexander Pool berichten
es ist der Tag der Chinesen besonders
gefragt der Stand des Herstellers das
e-automodell Dolphin der Name klingt
harmlos doch der Preis ist eine
Kampfansage
31.000 Euro in der Basisversion
vergleichbare deutsche Modelle liegen
fast 10.000 Euro darüber die deutschen
stehen im e-max noch nicht besonders gut
da sie sind relativ spät gekommen was
man auch erklären kann mit ihren großen
Erfolgen bei den bei den traditionellen
Autos also im Massengeschäft haben die
Deutschen bis ein echtes Problem da
fehlt einfach wirklich dass das gute
Angebot der schnell wachsende e-automat
ist heiß umkämpft dominiert von Tesla
führen bei den Zulassungszahlen die
chinesischen Marken Beyer die und SIP
vor VW und BMW wir merken dass die
Chinesen in den letzten Jahren ah das
Auto bauen gelernt haben sie haben eine
erhebliche Geschwindigkeit wenn es darum
geht digitalisierte Lösungen ins
Fahrzeug zu bringen und dann ist es auch
noch der Tag des Kanzlers zu Besuch auf
Zuspruch ist hier sehr willkommen denn
die Stimmung der deutschen Autobauer
trübt sich mehr und mehr ein in den 80er
Jahren hieß es jetzt überrollen
japanische Autos alle anderen Märkte 20
Jahre später waren es Autos made in
Korea heute sind es vermeintlich
chinesische Elektroautos und zugleich
steht doch die internationale
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit des autolandes
Deutschlands völlig außer Frage wie
ernst Tinas Herausforderung dennoch zu
sein scheint zeigt eine Äußerung vom
Bieber die Chef Wang Chong Fu dem
Marktführer in China in einem
patriotischen Aufruf forderte er Chinas
Autokonzerne dazu auf zusammen zu stehen
und die alten Legenden zu zerstören
die alten Legenden das sind auch die
deutschen Traditionshersteller Interview
und Fragen Link wie weit die ab doch mit
Bewerber nEO ist dazu bereit zur
Kampfansage der chinesischen Autobauer
jedoch kein Wort egal aus welchem Land
man Muskel globaler präsentierter sein
um überhaupt da auf den automotive
weltweite Industrie behaupten zu können
hinaus Autobauer haben einen Plan
Vorteil bei allem was ein Auto teuer
macht Batteriezellen und Halbleiter
können chinesische Firmen deutlich
billiger produzieren zumal die Rohstoffe
im eigenen Land gefördert werden dennoch
zeigen sich Deutschlands
Premiumhersteller sehr selbstbewusst
eine Markt wirklich zu erobern da müssen
Sie sehr viele ja Häkchen machen können
sie nicht einfach das Auto aus einer
anderen Weltregion versuchen hier zu
verkaufen sie müssen sehr gute
Ersatzteile besorgen aber sie brauchen
eine Menge Infrastruktur auf den
e-automat hat das Rennen längst begonnen
der Ausgang ist noch offen
der Ausgang ist noch offen fragen wir
nach bei Stefanie Barrett an der Börse
in Frankfurt Stefanie wie gefährlich ist
das für die deutsche Automobilindustrie
also die Zeiten wo Deutschlands
Autobauer die unangefochtene Supermacht
waren die sind vielleicht tatsächlich
vorbei denn im Grunde genommen wird die
Autowelt derzeit ganz neu aufgeteilt und
wie viel die deutschen Hersteller dann
am Ende davon abbekommen dass es heute
einfach noch sehr ungewiss fakt ist die
Chinesen verfügen über strategische
Wettbewerbsvorteile die kaum noch
aufzuholen sind alles aus einer Hand von
der Rohstoffen Mine bis zur Produktion
dazu preiswerte Energie so können Sie
sehr günstig bezahlbare E-Autos
produzieren dafür ist Deutschland aber
stark bei Innovation und Forschung und
verfügt über gute Ingenieure und viele
Mitarbeiter die gerade in den neuen
Technologien gut ausgebildet sind
auch ein bisschen war ja in der
Marktwirtschaft gibt es keine
ewigkeitsgarantien nur bei der deutschen
Automobilindustrie da steht ja wirklich
viel auf dem Spiel in der Tat die
deutsche Autobranche ist ja eine
Schlüsselindustrie und an den großen
Herstellern hängt ja auch die gesamte
Zulieferindustrie mit tausenden von
Arbeitsplätzen sie ist aber sehr
heterogen Bosch kontinental und ZF etwa
zählen zu den weltweit führenden
Zulieferern und haben dank ihrer starken
Kapitalpuffer aus den verbrennerzeiten
noch den Umstieg auf Elektroantrieb sehr
erfolgreich gemanagt sie sind hier sogar
Innovationstreiber und beliefern auch
Chinesen in diesem Segment kleinere und
weniger finanzkräftige Zulieferer
dagegen und das sind wirklich viele
werden den technologischen Wandel aber
wohl kaum überstehen danke schön nach
Frankfurt und mit dem Thema Klimaschutz
geht weiter
auf dem ersten klima-gipfel in Afrika
hat UN-Generalsekretär gut erneut mehr
Einsatz für den Klimaschutz gefordert
Afrika könne so wörtlich eine Supermacht
der erneuerbaren Energien werden das
mögliche afrikanische Wunder müsse aber
international unterstützt werden
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
bot in Nairobi Europa als
investitionspartner für Afrika an auch
die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate
kündigten an 4,2 Milliarden Euro in
saubere Energie in Afrika investieren zu
wollen
zum Afrika Klimagipfel gibt es im heute
journal Update ein Interview mit
Jennifer Morgan der Sonderbeauftragten
für internationale Klimapolitik im
Auswärtigen Amt zu sehen später um
Mitternacht hier im Programm
Bundesarbeitsminister Heil geht davon
aus dass es bis 2035 keinen Arbeitsplatz
mehr geben wird denn nichts mit
Anwendungen künstlicher Intelligenz zu
tun habe der Einsatz von KI für
Millionen Beschäftigte müsse aber
politisch gestaltet werden sagte Heil
die Arbeit werden nicht ausgehen sondern
sich verändern und es dürfen nicht außer
Acht gelassen werden dass diese
Entwicklung auch missbraucht werden
können
und noch eine Meldung vom Sport
Tennisprofi Alexander zwere steht im
Viertelfinale der US Open der 26 Jahre
alte Hamburger setzte sich in einem
packenden tenniskrimi in fünf Sätzen
gegen den Italiener Jannik Sinner durch
nachdem Mensch sprach wäre von einem der
besten Momente seiner Karriere im
Viertelfinale trifft er nun auf Titel
Verteidiger und Nummer eins der Welt
Carlos aus Spanien
[Applaus]
elvis ist über diese Ikone nicht schon
alles wirklich alles gesagt geschrieben
und verfilmt worden könnte man meinen
aber wenn sich dann eine kultregisseurin
wie Sophia koppola die Beziehung von
Elvis und seiner Frau Priscilla vornimmt
dann gibt es doch noch mal ganz neue
Einblick Film beruht auf den Memoiren
von Priscilla Presley und zeichnet das
Bild einer großen aber auch sehr
unglücklichen Liebe
Andreas Postel war dabei als der Film
jetzt in Venedig vorgestellt wurde
zwischen all dem Blitzlichtgewitter
blitzt ein Gedanke auf an diesem Abend
in Venedig wenn elvis lebt dann weil
Priscilla lebt und sie die Erinnerung an
diese amerikanische Ikone in diesem
Moment bis auf den roten Teppich von
Venedig trägt ihr Buch Elvis and Me ist
die Grundlage für den Film mit dem
Regisseurin Sophia Coppola ins Rennen um
die goldenen Löwen geht und er ist bei
all der zurückgekehrten männlichen
Dominanz ein feministisches
Ausrufezeichen genauso wie die junge
Hauptdarstellerin Kylies Benny die im
Film die Priscilla verkörpert
es war mir wirklich wichtig dass ich
ihre Geschichte richtig präzise und
authentisch anfühlt und ich auch die
kreative Freiheit habe einen Film zu
machen deshalb hat es mir sehr viel
bedeutet dass Priscilla sagte dass es
richtig gemacht wurde entstanden ist ein
coming age Drama im Superstar Milieu aus
der Perspektive von Priscilla damals
blutjunge 14 Jahre alt verführt vom
charismatischen Popstar während seiner
Armeezeit in Bad Nauheim erzählt diese
unglaubliche Liebesgeschichte mit viel
Raum für Zwischentöne eine Opfer Täter
Story ist das nicht auch wenn der King
of Rock n' Roll Sie in die Rolle seiner
Königin zwingt einer Königin im goldenen
Käfig von Graceland aus dem Priscilla am
Ende ausbricht
ich war wirklich beeindruckt von ihrer
Geschichte und ihrer Stärke dass sie ihn
am Ende verlassen konnte weißt du ihr
ganzes Leben drehte sich um diese Ehe es
muss für sie besonders zu dieser Zeit
damals wirklich schwer gewesen sein zu
gehen und für sich zu sein
es war das Glamour Party des
amerikanischen Jette 60er Jahre der Film
zeigt nun die dunkelste Seite von der
Elvis je gezeigt wurde und andererseits
die tief empfundene Liebe zwischen den
beiden auf der Pressekonferenz sind
Venedig ergreift die heute 78-Jährige
Priscilla Presley auf Nachfrage spontan
das Wort und bestätigt diese Version
wir bauten eine Beziehung auf und diese
Beziehung dauerte an bis ich ihn verließ
und das nicht weil ich ihn nicht liebte
er war die Liebe meines Lebens es war
sein Lebensstil der so schwierig für
mich war und ich glaube jede Frau kann
das nachempfinden
für Sophia war es genau diese Ambivalenz
erzählt sie im Interview diese
Geschichte einer jungen Frau die ihren
Weg sucht und findet
ich bin immer neugierig wie Menschen
aufwachsen und ihre Identität finden und
aus diesem Grund habe ich mich in sie
als junges Mädchen hineinversetzt aber
ich konnte die Geschichte auch aus der
Sicht der Eltern eines teenager-mädchens
erzählen und so war es interessant zu
versuchen ihre Geschichte mit allen
Höhen und Tiefen darzustellen ohne zu
urteilen und hoffentlich ihre
Erfahrungen zu vermitteln
nicht zuletzt ihre beiden
Hauptdarsteller Kylie Spenny und Jacob
alordi bekommen auf dem roten Teppich
viel Applaus und machen den Film zu
einem der bislang interessantesten des
diesjährigen Festivals
[Musik]
das war's heute schon mal gleich im
Anschluss empfehle ich Ihnen die 37°
Reportage heute mit einem Thema das
hierzulande über 6 Millionen Erwachsene
betrifft Menschen die aus
unterschiedlichen Gründen nicht richtig
lesen und schreiben können
Nazan guckte mir meldet sich also um
Mitternacht mit unserem Update und wir
uns morgen wieder auf Wiedersehen
tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend das stabile hoch über
Mitteleuropa diese sogenannte Omega
Wetterlage hat allerdings auch seine
Kehrseite zum einen ein Tiefe mit dem
Atlantik ein ehemaliger Hurrikan und
hier über den zentralen und östlichen
Mittelmeer hat sich ein Tief namens
Daniel jedenfalls international so
genannt entwickelt und das bringt enorme
Regenmengen mit in Mittel- und in
Nordgriechenland hat es schon hunderte
Liter Regen pro Quadratmeter gegeben und
damit reicht es noch nicht denn auch in
den nächsten Tagen bis Donnerstag
erwarten wir weitere kräftige Regenfälle
das sehen Sie hier an der dunkelblauen
Färbung da können noch mal bis zu 700
Liter Regen pro Quadratmeter fallen ganz
anders ist das Wetter bei uns heute
Nacht ist es meist klar selten bildet
sich etwas Nebel und die Temperaturen
sinken auf 16 bis 7 Grad jetzt im
September ist der Tagesgang der
Temperaturen interessant das schauen wir
uns am Beispiel von Hannover an in den
nächsten Stunden wird erstmal kälter
kurz nach Sonnenaufgang werden die
tiefsten Temperaturen erreicht das sind
nächsten Morgen früh in Hannover so um
die 14 Grad und dann schwingen sich die
Temperaturen auf 30 Grad auf und das
wird so gegen 17 Uhr sein dann werden
die Höchstwerte erreicht in Deutschland
sonst liegen die Höchsttemperaturen
zwischen 25 Grad auf Rügen und 32 Grad
am Niederrhein dazu gibt es sehr viel
Sonnenschein und das bleibt auch in den
nächsten Tagen so bei Temperaturen von
26 bis 32 Grad ich wünsche Ihnen noch
einen schönen Abend